ARE VERY COMPETENT, TRUSTWORTHY
SCIENTIST.
>> Sean: JOINING US WITH
REACTION, SENATOR JOHN KENNEDY
OF LOUISIANA.
SENATOR.
FIRST IT WAS NO MASK.
A MASK ISN'T GOING TO WORK.
THEN ONE MASK, TWO MASKS.
THEN MAYBE MASKS IN PERPETUITY.
THEN HE TOLD US IF WE GOT THE
VACCINE WE WOULD NEVER CONTRACT
COVID.
NOW PEOPLE THAT HAVE THE
VACCINE, THEY HAVE TWO SHOTS AND
THEY HAVE TWO BOOSTERS AND THEY
HAVE PREVIOUS INFECTION.
NOW THEY ARE GETTING COVID A
SECOND TIME.
THEY WERE WRONG ON THE SCIENCE.
THE WORST PART TO ME IS THE LIE
AND THAT IS DON'T WE KNOW KNOW
FOR FACT THAT NIH MONEY,
TAXPAYER DOLLARS WENT TO FUND
THIS WUHAN VIROLOGY LAB AND THEY
KNEW GAIN-OF-FUNCTION RESEARCH
AND CORONAVIRUS RESEARCH TOOK
PLACE AT THAT FACILITY.
>> TWO POINTS, SEAN.
NUMBER ONE, AS I THINK I HAVE
TOLD YOU BEFORE.
I DON'T HATE ANYONE.
THAT INCLUDES DR. FAUCI.
HE HAS DECIDED TO RETIRE IN
DECEMBER, AND I WISH HIM WELL.
HOWEVER, THIS IS MY SECOND
POINT.
UNLESS YOU DO YOUR RESEARCH ON
TWITTER, YOU KNOW THAT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE MANY, MANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW DR. FAUCI,
OTHER PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS.
AND OUR GOVERNMENT HANDLED THE
PANDEMIC.
GETTING ANSWERS TO THOSE
QUESTIONS FROM DR. FAUCI AND
OTHERS HAS BEEN LIKE TRYING TO
SLAM A REVOLVING DOOR.
DEMOCRATS ARE IN CHARGE, THEY
REFUSED TO PRESS.
THE REPUBLICANS WILL.
HERE'S MY PREDICTION, IF
REPUBLICANS TAKE ONE OR BOTH
HOUSES OF CONGRESS.
AND UNLESS DR. FAUCI, RETIREMENT
OR NOT DECIDES TO SEEK ASYLUM IN
SOME REMOTE, OBSCURE FOREIGN
COUNTRY.
SP1 MAY BE WUHAN, CHINA, WILL
TAKE HIM.
>> UNLESS DR. FAUCI DECIDES TO
SEEK ASYLUM IN SOME FOREIGN
COUNTRY WHOSE POWERBALL JACKPOT
IS 287 CHICKENS AND A GOAT AND
THEREFORE WHICH WON'T ENFORCE A
SUBPOENA FROM THE UNITED STATES
CONGRESS, THEN DR. FAUCI,
RETIREMENT OR NOT, IS GOING TO
BE SPENDING A LOT OF TIME IN
FRONT OF A CONGRESSIONAL
COMMITTEE AND COMMITTEES IF
REPUBLICANS TAKE BACK CONTROL.
WE'RE GOING TO ASK HIM QUESTIONS
ABOUT GAIN-OF-FUNCTION RESEARCH,
WHY HE DIDN'T PUSH BACK ON
CHINA'S LIES, WHY HE PUSHED BACK
SO HARD ON THE POSSIBILITY WHICH
WE KNOW IS NO REAL, THAT THE
VIRUS ORIGINATED IN A CHINESE
LAB.
WHY HE WENT ALONG WITH THE
GREATEST DISSIPATION IF THAT'S
THE RIGHT WORD, THE GREATEST
TAKING OF CIVIL LIBERTIES, OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE IN THE
HISTORY OF OUR COUNTRY, WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE A LOT OF QUESTIONS
HERE WE ARE GOING TO SUBPOENA
HIM AND EXPECT HIM TO ANSWER.
I WOULD NOT ADVISE DR. FAUCI TO
PUT DOWN A NONREFUNDABLE DEPOSIT
ON A CRUISE.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU, WE
HAVE HIS EMAILS IN JANUARY 2020
AND A FLURRY OF EMAILS AMONG
OTHER NIH EXECUTIVES THAT SEEM
TO SHOW GREAT CONCERN WHAT MIGHT
BE FOUND OUT ABOUT MONIES GOING
TO THE WUHAN VIROLOGY LAB.
THAT INTERCEPT, THE 900 PAGES.
PROJECT VERY TOSS.
AND THEN WE HAVE I BELIEVE IT
WAS OCTOBER OF 2020 OR 2021, THE
NIH'S OWN EMAIL SHOW THAT THEY
KNEW ABOUT GAIN-OF-FUNCTION
RESEARCH.
DO YOU BELIEVE DR. FAUCI
PURPOSELY LIED TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ABOUT WHAT HE KNEW ABOUT
THE CORONAVIRUS, ABOUT THE WUHAN
VIROLOGY LAB COMMENT ABOUT
AMERICAN TAX DOLLARS FUNDING
GAIN OF FUNCTION?
>> I DON'T KNOW BUT WE NEED TO
FIND OUT.
IT'S NOT ABOUT REPUBLICANS OR
DEMOCRATS, AND IT'S NOT ABOUT
DR. FAUCI.
IT'S ABOUT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THEY HAVE BEEN THROUGH HELL IN
PART ON THE ADVICE OF DR. FAUCI.
MAYBE HE WAS RIGHT.
BUT MAYBE HE WAS WRONG.
THE LAST CONVERSATION I HAD WITH
DR. FAUCI WITH RESPECT TO MY
BEAR NO ILL WILL, HE WAS IN
FRONT OF A COMMITTEE.
THEY ONLY GAVE ME 5 MINUTES.
I ASKED HIM A SIMPLE QUESTION,
WHAT DID WE LEARN FROM THE
PANDEMIC.
I GOT A FELONIOUS AMOUNT OF B.S.
THE DEMOCRATS WILL PRESS BUT IF
WE TAKE BACK CONTROL OF THIS
CONGRESS, WE WILL.
RETIREMENT OR NOT, HE WILL BE
SUBJECT TO A CONGRESSIONAL
SUBPOENA.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DESERVE
ANSWERS.
THEY HAVE BEEN THROUGH HELL.
TO SAY NOTHING OF THE FACT THAT
WE MAY HAVE TO GO THROUGH THIS
SOMETIME AGAIN SOON.